unless you're continuing your campaign
in the Champions bracket this must feel
good right now especially after a
victory with the black pieces
I found
I felt more of hoping to stay solid and
like not lose that's more important
um but I felt like I had like no idea
what to do in the opening but I felt it
was actually very interesting after I
was able to after she castled greenside
and then I was able to play this move
Knight to G4 yeah so she's I think sort
of forced to play bishopy one and then I
win the H2 Pawn after that I wasn't sure
I thought like it was a bit awkward for
me because after she like played Bishop
H3 and it was this move Bishop to E2
that seems to have played in her favor
did you consider this move at all or
um yeah I thought I would play E4 and I
was actually a bit more concerned about
Bishop G2 and then she might have Like
Queenie two ideas but author E4 Queen to
E2 ideas but I guess I have F5 that's
interesting I didn't really like that
move but
um apparently then I probably will play
like Knight G4
so I guess the difference is after
Bishop E2 I wouldn't want to play F5 and
Knight G4 because uh the G6 pawn and
then also like I get trip upon that's
right so I was planning to play E4 after
that and then I hit up three and I
thought that
um I thought that was actually Pleasant
for me
um because I would be able to like win
the pond and I think the big difference
is that she's probably going to take
take and then make space for the queen
to Corral your Pawn with Queen D1 Queen
F3 this seems to lead to a very complex
battle but you are pretty happy with
this position right yeah I thought uh I
thought I had a good chance it's like B6
I was happy about because I don't think
it was possible like
um earlier before we traded off the
pieces
um you mean some around here yeah I
didn't I thought B6 uh then yeah there's
D takes C5 so it wouldn't be nearly as
good although I guess it's still
playable
um but I was more happy because I was
were to close the center so she wouldn't
have any E4 idea since my cane is still
in the center
um and you got to this position and she
played this rather awkward move G4 it
felt a bit slow gave you the tempo to
play B6 and open up the position
that must have felt good and inspiring
for you yeah I thought um
[Music]
that would that was also too slow yeah
um so I was happy with this B6 move and
then after Knight takes B6 I felt my
position was very good because I have
these really interesting ideas
um
so I was sort of focused on this idea of
Knight C4 and my idea is I want to play
Bishop A3 so if she doesn't do anything
um then I have this bishop A3 b6a3 Queen
takes A3 uh kindy one Knight B2 kidney 2
Queen I6 and that's I think let's just
play A Move by three
um Knight B2 King E2 Queen I said and I
was happy with his Queen A6 move and I
thought I definitely have a lot of
interesting ideas and if she goes the
other way to B1 then The Rook is coming
yeah and then like grippy two and Knight
D2 and Knight B3 this is game over yeah
so she had to go for this rock to h8
Rook to b8id to cover up the B file that
Rook to B7 was coming with tremendous
consequences and this is the move that
we found very uh very cool to see look
to see yeah so
um here uh I thought if she did work B7
then her work is like just really bad
I'll probably picking eight uh and I
always have ideas of like Knight P6 or
Knight D6 and the work is just not happy
326 as well so after she traded
um I thought I was better I was pretty
happy with the position and what I was
hoping for is instead of Bishop takes up
three
um I thought she could if she didn't
Knight takes E4 of this move 91 so
that's pretty nice
um but I think she probably saw it
otherwise uh
um but here it's good because she
actually has no easy way to get to the
F3 pawn and uh after Knight B1 Queen
takes they do she doesn't have many
moves left that are possible yeah this
position is just simply lost and you
converted it with clinical Precision
Alice uh you must be sensing already
that semi-final well what's your thought
about that uh I didn't think too much
about this today thought I was trying
not to lose so I thought there might be
a playoff and I was fine with that but
for right now I'm happy of course to
advance and I'll be playing either
probably a vegamar Arena so either Irina
or begging but it does seem like Irina
is in pole position to take this one
home yeah so it would be similar to last
year I did lose two matches against her
last year but that definitely was some
good experience for me so I'll try my
best I'm not expecting too much but
hopefully it will go better this time
guys any questions no no just
congratulations Alice and good luck in
your next match
thank you and once again that's really